I use something called the rule of 100
you advertise your stuff by doing 100
primary actions every day 100 days in a
row are you emailing 100 times a day
period yes or no if you're not doing it
do that first and you might be like wow
that's going to take me like 4 hours yep
and then you're going to have your
workday start welcome to owning a small
business you have to know how to do more
and the first Baseline that I want
everyone to get through is doing 100 a
day because you will appreciate one the
value of a lead and two you will develop
such a good skill set from getting that
many repetitions in that you'll be able
to transfer and teach it to other people
and knowing how to make it rain as a
business owner is probably the single
most valuable skill that you can have
because for the rest of your life you
will never worry about eating because
you can always pick up the phone and
make money